great so I think let's get started because we have a lot to cover today uh so my name is Yan uh for those who don't know me I'm a third-year PhD student advised by Tatsu and Percy and today I'll be talking about benchmarking and evaluations uh so benchmarking and evaluations are honestly something that I think not enough people look at in Academia uh but if you really want to put something in production and you really care about let's say real world machine learning uh evaluation is really
key so let's talk about that so overview of what we'll talk about first is uh different reasons for measuring performance uh then I'll talk about text classification and and how you measure performance there then text generations and how you measure performance there and finally like how do you evaluate Uh current large language models um and some issues and challenges with the ways that we actually to perform evaluations okay so my mental model of how you actually develop a machine
learning model is that first you will be uh training your model uh so here measuring performance is really key uh because you need to have a loss um that you need to know when basically how to optimize um then once you are optimizing your loss the second step is basically development uh so usually this is highi tuning or for example if you have um early stopping during your models like if you see that your model is not performing that well you might or that there's like some overfitting happening
you might decide to to stop or you might decide to like change the learning rate during the training of your model so development is kind of the Second Step um and here you need to measure performance because you need to know how to do actually uh models uh sorry High Prim tuning um and and like changing High parameters uh then the third step is essentially model selection so if I have a task that I really care about uh which model performs best for my task that might be a model that I have trained it might be a model that another
group has trained uh and finally at least in the real world you would decide to deploy your model and here per uh measuring performance is really key because you need to know whether your model is good enough to put in production um in the parallel universe that we live in there's also the publishing uh so you basically need to um test like evaluate a model on standing bench marks and the reason why we do that is essentially for communicating to different groups the quality of our bottle so at every step
of this pipeline you really need to measure performance and that's what we'll talk about today but what is key to understand is that at different steps you need to measure performance in different ways so there's really not a single way of of uh not a single ideal way of measuring performance so for example on the left when you train your model uh for evaluating performance you really need to uh have a way of measuring performance that is super fast super cheap uh and differentiable because
usually I mean with new networks you basically back propagate through the loss so it needs to be differentiable and finally you really cannot have a way for your model to optimize some shortcuts um to optimize the loss even though it's not really what you wanted to optimize uh and as you move more to the right basically you you allowed or like you will you will um measure performance uh less often so it's fine if it's more expensive uh but you really like the the risk that that um or you
really need your perform your measuring like your your evaluation metrics to be higher quality uh because um the issues if you put a model in production are higher um so during the development stage you need a way of measuring performance that is fast cheap and also kind of avoiding shortcuts because when you do high PR tuning you're essentially also optimizing over certain objective uh model selection it can be a little bit less fast and less cheap but still you will have to do it that many
many times and most importantly when you deploy a model you really want the way to evaluate performance to be trustworthy uh because once you put something in production there's kind of no way to go back for what happened during that time where it was in production uh you also want things to be very task specific so if I care about a certain task when I put when I put my model in production H it really you really need to evaluate on that specific task I don't care about other tasks and finally you need your metrics to be
absolute uh so the reason why I'm highlighting that is that in the in the three other steps you really just care about comparing between things um so that is very different than if you if you want to kind of have a a threshold which says if I have less than 95% accuracy I'm not putting my model in production okay and now let's talk about publishing this is a little bit different than honesty evaluation in the real world uh but when you publ when you basically do academic benchmarking and
when you evaluate uh your models and academic benchmarks you want the Benchmark to be reproducible and standardized and the reason why is basically because for the next five or six or 10 years everyone will be evaluated on that one Benchmark and you want papers in three years to be comparable to yours uh so it's really important that your evaluations are reproducible honestly you don't really care about that in the real world um you also want things to be easy to work with because researchers are uh usually a
little bit they don't want to do additional work that they need to uh and also they usually don't have that much resource so it needs to be fast and and and cheap um and finally one one thing which I really want to highlight is that for the academic benchmarks that we usually have it's fine if the metrics that we use are not perfect because really what matters is that over 10 years uh the direction that your metrix is showing you to to go into like basically the how the field is moving um really if if the metric is
saying that it's slightly better uh sorry that it's better over 10 years that in reality the the the field has made some progress um so at a meta level it's fine if you use crude metrics in in um in Academia and also you kind of need to um to balance between difficulty and simplicity and what I mean by that is that if your benchmark is way too complicated uh then basically all methods will have essentially random performance so no one will use your benchmark and if uh your benchmark is
too simple then the basine will be so good that no one will use your benchmark because no one can beat the the the Baseline this is really something that is specific to Academia in the real world you're not going to be able to change the Tas that you're performing uh based on like how good your model is so that's why I I kind of just want to highlight that because usually people talk about evaluations but there's really different like different ways of evaluating and different reasons why we
evaluate is that all makes sense also feel free to ask questions great Okay so benchmarks in Academia this is really the way we drive the field so this is The mlu Benchmark I think archit briefly mentioned it but I'll talk about it later again um so this is the most standard Benchmark right now and you basically see that in the last 4ish years uh it has gone from 25% accuracy which is essentially random because uh it's multiple choice um and there are four choices to around 90 is% accuracy um so yeah benchmarking is
really what Drive the the the progress in the field and again you see what I mean here what I meant here is that it's not really the differences between small points that matter at least in Academia you have to take a step back and you have to think what matters is is like how your models will perform over 10 years and making sure that the model on the top right here is better than the model on the top on the bottom left um even if the if even if the Benchmark is not perfect and I I think mlu is a
pretty good one in that sense okay so there are two main types at least classically of um tasks in in NLP um close ended tasks uh so I'll talk about it later but essentially you can think about classification where you know exactly uh the label the correct label for uh the task that you're performing so here this is the IMDB data set where you're asked to say whether a sentence is has positive sentiment or negative sentiment so the text is read the book forget the movie so this is about uh sentiment classification of the
movie so here it's basically negative um and then there's open-ended evaluation so think about Chad GPT like how do you evaluate something like that where really there's no correct answer uh and there are many or there are many possible correct answers and they all have like different qualities um so we're going to distinguish between those two so close ended evaluation so as I just said close ended tasks uh there's a limited it's Define one uh as the task where is's a limited
number of potential answers um think like less than 10 um and often there's just one or maybe a few correct POS possible answers um so this really is standard machine learning if you think about standard classification you can just do accuracy you can look at your Precision your recalls um there's nothing special here about NLP uh that is not to me to say that it's simple it's just that there's nothing special about NP here uh so some tasks some uh close-ended tasks I already told you about uh
sentiment analysis so usually this is a binary binary classification task where you just have to say whether the sentiment is positive or whether it's negative uh another task is entailment um also for sentiment analysis the typical benchmarks I always put it next to the task uh is IMDb and SST from Stanford entailment is snli also from Stanford where basically you have some text so here a soccer game with multiple males playing and then you have a hypothesis some men are playing Sport and you have to say whether the
hypothesis is implied or entailed by the text uh so here it is uh other tasks part of speech uh typical Benchmark um pentry bank and name entity recognition uh which is a caral uh Benchmark a few other tasks you don't need to know all of them but just to give you a brief overview uh cor reference resolution um so this is actually a pretty challenging uh NLP task where you have to say what pronoun which pronoun refers to what noun so you have here the sentence Mark told Pete many lies about himself uh himself which
Pete included in his book uh he should have been more truthful and now you have to say uh what does he refer to um whether he refers to Pete and then there question answering uh where you basically have a long text and you ask a question and uh well the test ask a question and you're supposed to provide an answer based on the on the text that you have before so those are some examples of of uh close ended tasks and again uh the key here is that the way we evaluate those is just standard machine
learning you can look at accuracy precision recall F1 score uh hopefully you all know about these type of metrics but if you don't you should look at um Chris Peach's uh class uh I think it's cs224u uh but his lecture is online and it's actually really good um on different metrics um so the ways that people evaluate some of these benchmarks uh is usually by looking at many of them uh concurrently uh so the most common I would say like super or multitask Benchmark is called superglue um so here
you see on the on the columns here you have all the different tasks uh in super glue so I think there are eight or nine um and then you you really just look at the average uh performance in each of these benchmarks and you get a ranking on that and that is kind of a attempt to measure General language capabilities um this is what people used to do I would say until maybe two years ago um I will tell you about what people do now uh around the end of the lecture uh but yeah super glue is is definitely
something you should at least be aware of uh and the example of tasks uh that are in superglue uh one is a bull Q which is simply you have some text you have some question and you have to say whether the answer is yes or whether it's no so that's very easy to evaluate you just look at accuracies or Precision recall uh entailment we already talked about um and then the other ones like co- reference resolution which we also talked about and meaning of words which is something where you have two
sentences with uh the same words and you have to say whether they actually mean the same thing in this sentence for example if if you have Bank could mean Bank like water and Bank like money and you have to say whether in these two sentences um they refer to the same concept uh and there are some question answering tasks too um so this is about super clue are there any questions no cool um so again although I said many times that this is essentially just classical machine learning uh I want to emphasize that it doesn't mean
that it's simple and and you really have to think carefully about what you do when you use those type of close-ended tasks in particular you're going to have to choose whether you look at accuracies Precision recall F1 score Rock curves Au curves if you don't know these names you should really check out the es learn uh documentation or the lecture from Chris Peach that I that I I linked above um both of which are really good but depending on which metric you will choose uh you will have very you will
decide on very different type of algorithms and the usual example is is that if um let's say you look at uh spam you want to do classification of whether um a email is spammed or not most emails are not spammed uh thankfully at least I hope um so let's say that 90% of emails were actually not spam and only 10% of them are spam uh if you look at the accuracy then just a random classifier uh that predicts the most likely label will get 90% accuracy um and that seems if you don't know really about your data
set like 90% accur seems good but in reality here it means that you're not classifying anything um so that's why you want to look at Precision recall and Fon call um anyways I will not talk too much about that because again this is not specific to NLP but it doesn't mean it's easy um another issue is that once you have multiple different tasks there's a question of how do you aggregate these metrics so right before I told you oh you just take the average between all of these things this
honestly is a really terrible thing of do um to do but that's actually what people do um but these columns actually mean very different things some of them are accuracies others are F1 score others are correlations uh and you just average everything I can't remember which uh Benchmark but I remember a few years ago there was one Benchmark where actually one of the columns was uh you were better basically you had better performance if the if the value was lower and you still took an average of
these things until someone realized like maybe we should take a put a minus there so uh um so yeah be careful and like don't always think that what people do in in in Academia or like in yeah that what people do is correct um you should think a little bit uh about that then there are some other questions I want you to think about uh where do those labels come from I said that is usually a a real answer but how you actually get those La labels is is unclear so I will tell you about like some issues uh in
the next slide and uh and also related to that the might be some superious correlations and that's what we're going to talk about right now so we already talked about um snli so uh entailment so here you have again your premise the E economy could still be better uh and the hypothesis the economy has never been better and you have to say whether the hypothesis is implied by the premise uh and what this paper from 2019 found that actually all the different models were performing really well but if you looked
if you just classified based on the hypothesis you could also perform really well so even if you did not look at the at the premise which seems like something that you need to take into account because it's part of the task you could perform well and the reason why is because uh they realized that when the humans actually wrote the the hypothesis they will ask oh write a hypothesis which is not entailed by the premise and how humans usually do that is by adding a negation um so if you only look at the hypothesis and you see
this a negation it's very likely that it's not entailed by uh by the premise um so again even though this is standard machine learning be really careful about what metric you use and what where do the labels come from uh and don't do everything like don't just use what people do thinking that like if there was an issue people would have realized um so yeah so that is Pur correlations uh any questions on close ended task cool okay open-ended evaluations I'm going to mostly talk about that because
this is what is specific to uh NLP um so open-ended evaluation or open-ended task is essentially the opposite of the close ended task which is to say that there are many possible correct answers and you cannot enumerate all of them um so you really can't use standard machine learning metrics uh and more oops um even more than the the fact that you cannot enumerate all the possible answers usually uh there are different levels of correctness so if I ask you to write a book or if I ask chpt to write a book like it might be a
decent book but it might be a better book uh that it could have written or that another model could write so it's not just right and wrong there's like diff it's a Continuum or or yeah it's a Continuum uh so stand examples for open-ended tasks the two most common ones are summarization um so summarization you have a long uh piece of text and you just ask to summarize it in less than X characters um standard Benchmark is the C uh CNN and daily mail um Benchmark so the way they actually uh
um collected that data set is that they took a lot of CNN articles and you know at the top of CNN articles you have bullet points uh that kind of say like what are the most important things in the article so they use this as the as essentially the gold summary um so this is the classic one for summarization for translation you basically have sentences in two different languages and you have to translate from one to the other uh so those are the classical ones uh the way that people currently do it is I would
say the the most standard task right now is instruction following instruction following is kind of the uh the mother of all tasks in the sense that um you can view any previous task as just a chat bot or like some question that you ask to basically chat GP you can think classification I could just ask CH GPT to do that you can think summarization I could ask CH GPT to do that so essentially you could just view a chatbot as the most General type of task and you can per you can ask it to perform any possible task and it should
just provide the answer for that task uh so this is what we call instruction following uh so as you might think um evaluation is very hard in that domain uh and that's what we'll talk about later is how do you evaluate something like CH GPT okay so types of evaluation methods for text generation or open-ended tasks um the classical ones are content overlap metrix which I'll talk about then so that's really comparing just the the the words between a reference answer a gold answer that humans wrote and the actual
Generation generation that you got from your model uh then there's a there are model based metrics where you basically uh turn evaluation into machine learning so you ask a you train a model to basically become an evaluator um and then there human evaluation which is uh usually seen as the gold standard for open-ended tasks so content overlap metrics so as I just said this is really just comparing word by word um or group of words between the generated sequence and some reference um so here I have the
generated sequence being the woman went to the hardware store and the gold reference which is uh the reference written by humans I actually don't even know what the task is but the reference here is they walk to the grocery store and then what you do is that you just compare uh the two different sentences by looking at the lexical similarity between those two texts um and this is super fast and efficient and the way you usually do that is by using engram overlap metrix so what I mean by this is that uh the
simplest possible thing is just to say whether for every word in the generated sequence whether it appears in the reference sequence and if if it does then you kind of increment um your performance uh so engrams is essentially the same thing but instead of looking at a single word you basically look at Iams trigrams and and and kind of um uh multiple words uh next to one another so the usual overlap metrix the most common ones are blue and Rouge uh blue means blue and Rouge means red um that's not
what they stand for though and I I always forget what they stand for uh but basically blur what it is is that it's a engram overlap metric that um tries to look at Precision while Rouge is what looks at it looks at the recall uh so as I as I said before as alluded before what is important even if you turn everything into a kind of sentence classification you have to think about whether you care about Precision or recall um so those metrics are not ideal but until I would say two years ago they
would have gold standard for translation and summarization uh for translation people use blue uh because you really want to yeah you really want you basically look at the let's say I'm translating from French to English uh I want to look at the uh generated sequence in English and the actual reference sequence in English and I want to know whether every uh Bagram that I generated appears or like how many of the bams that I I generated appears in the uh in the reference sequence um the there's one additional thing which is
that they don't only look at Precision because you could get a very high Precision by actually predicting something very small uh for example if you always predicted the word the only generated the word the you would most likely get very high Precision uh because the usually appears in every sentence or like let's say a full stop um so there's also like some length penalty uh and Rouge is kind of the opposite it just look said we call um so those are the the common the common content overlap metrics and I'll just to
illustrate why those are not ideal um well they have many issues but one of them is that they don't really take into account the the semantic relatedness between words um so imagine that Chris asks you are you enjoying the cs224 N lectures uh of course the the gold answer is heck yes um so that's the reference answer so now let's say that the model just generates yes so here what you're going to have is if I look at the blue the blue score uh I will have 67% uh um essentially blue score because
two of the words that I generated or two of the unigrams I generated are in the reference um in the gold reference if I generate you know it then I will only have a single um token in the generated sequence that appears in the reference sequence which is the exclamation point uh I get a much lower um blue score and if I just say yep then that doesn't appear at all in the generated uh sorry in the reference sequence so I get zero uh blue score which is a false negative because really it literally means the
same thing as uh heck yes um so hopefully you see that like these metrics really have issues um also you can have false positives for example if you say heck no uh then most of the words are the same so you get 7% uh blue score um but it really means something completely different uh does that make sense any questions cool so very naturally now that you know everything about what it Bings what you might ask is oh why do we look at words if what we could do is looking at like learn representations
which really kind of uh maintain the the semantic similarity uh between words uh so this is exactly what people have done um around 2019 I think is that they took uh some some or even before actually 2016 they took some word embeddings um they Associated every word in the uh in the reference sequence to a word embedding every word um in the generated sequence to the corresponding word embedding and they basically started comparing the word embeddings so a very simple way of comparing word embeddings
is just you take the average uh between the word embeddings in the reference sequence and the average between the word embeddings in the generated sequence and you maybe look at cosine similarity I mean there are mod ways of doing it but honestly at this point it's not that important uh so you can think about averaging um another one uh as you know at this point um what embeddings don't really take into account the contextual um or like the context of the of where the word basically appears uh
so better way of getting good representations for for word is by looking essentially at at BIR so what you could do is you could take a bird model you could pass the generated sequence through it you get some embeddings um and then you can take bird again the same bird you pass the reference sequence to it you get some other embeddings and then you do again some comparison I mean this bird score uh pretty famous paper they do like some smart comparison but it it's not that important to understand what EX exactly
they do um what is important is that they take like some smart averaging um between those words cool any questions okay um so that was the simplest uh the simplest type of of meth of learning methods which is uh word uh word matching another slightly more complicated one is called blurt also pretty famous which is a mix between blur and bird uh so the the way that they did that is that basically they they took a pre-trained bir um and then they do some continual pre-training by trying to predict the the blur score and
some other metrics and then they fine-tune that's the important part is that they F tune the pre-train model uh to actually do the evaluation that they care about so let's say that I have a lot of different uh sequences and I I I have some human annotations of how I should be evaluating it I could just treat that as a normal machine learning task and I just fine-tune my bir uh to do the evaluation so this is blurt any questions yes curious if you pre-train on uh blue wouldn't it cause the same
problems as the if you if your pre-training fast is blue then your would learn the ability to model languages semantically in the first place yeah uh that's a very good point so actually I I also find it kind of surprising so they did two things first they do the real pre-training of of uh of bird and then they do continual pre-training for predicting uh blue and the reason why is because usually they say we have a lot of uh sequences in our data set that are unlabeled so we have like some reference um sequences and
some uh generated sequences but we don't have like the human annotation of whether this is good or bad so we will treat that as unsupervised learning objective uh so what you use for the supervised learning objective well you have to use something and they basically use blur and they also use actually um uh Bird score so they use like many different tasks and they basically do multitask learning cool okay so one important uh issue with all these methods is that really they are they can only be as good as the
references are and in reality the references are usually not that good uh so this is in part this is a paper that looks at summarization um of news so basically as I said before most of the news summarization benchmarks um they they usually take the the reference uh summary as being the bullet points that you find at the top of an article um and this is usually not that good so here what you see on the um sorry on on the left this is what if you look at the correlation between the x-axis being the
the human uh rate of or like the human evaluated performance of every model and on the y- axis you see the uh Rouge L which is just a variant of rouge um and you look at whether uh basically these two are correlated and what you see is that it essentially not correlated which means that rou L on standard um references is really not correlated to what humans would say is a good summary um that is not to say that rou is a bad score that is to say that actually the references are bad because if you look
at the exact same thing uh but now you ask experts to write very good summaries uh then you see that the correlation actually increases by a decent amount still not perfect uh Rouge is definitely not perfect but at least it's much better um so this is to say that the metric itself is is not always perfect but not only this the the references are usually actually uh not great cool so that begs a very natural question which is can we just dump uh and Le yeah basically move away from reference based evaluation so as we just
said uh reference based evaluations are the ones that compare human written references to some model outputs uh using some different type of metrics um and those used to be the standard metrics for evaluating or the standard Benchmark for evaluating NLP tasks uh I would say up to like 2 or 3 years ago right now now I think uh papers still have to always show the blue scores like for example in Translation um because review is W those but I'm I don't think like anyone in in uh in the real world
actually uses them but I might be wrong on that um so yeah so blue Rouge Bird score oh and I was mostly talking about blue and Rouge Bird score is actually still uh decently used and and actually pretty good okay so reference free evaluation so reference free evaluation is uh basically you have a model and you ask it to give a score uh but there are no human references um so the way that this is that this used to be done is essentially by taking a model like like B again but instead of comparing between
a reference a reference answer and the generated answer you could just ask it to to take the input and just predict the score uh that's like one simple way of doing it that used to really not work well uh and I say used to because until basically Chad GPT and GPT 4 uh now what people do and honestly that works super well is that you just ask gp4 to do the uh the same task as you would ask a human so you give like a very long uh text and then you uh you give the generated summary and you ask like how
good is it essentially and that works uh surprisingly well um so common benchmarks here alpaca eval and empty bench uh there are many others now honestly most people uh start using these type of of techniques um but we'll be talking at least about app Eva um good okay so let's talk a little bit about human evaluation before looping back to um to basically gp4 um so as we saw the metrics until now they are they all have some shortcomings um and they definitely not as good as if you ask directly human
evaluation because they are based on on um on references uh so human evaluation is really the goal standard for open-ended uh open ended tasks um and not only is it really the the standard way of doing evaluation or like the goal standard for evaluation it's also the gold standard for developing new automatic evaluations so every time you you develop a new automatic evaluations you will want to compare to uh what humans would have basically uh predicted um yeah okay so doing human evaluation i'
first it might seem very simple you basically ask humans to evaluate the quality of some generated text seems simple right uh but actually it's super complicated and it's a it's a real like Challenge and it has many issues so first um oh sorry I I'll talk about that before maybe one additional thing is that you should not only ask the human you usually ask it also to um ask them to evaluate across different axes for example the fluency of the text or the coherence of the text or like common
sense or like the the style grammaticality redundancy and like different axes that you might care about um another thing to note is that you should absolutely never compare uh different human evaluations so if there's one paper that says oh uh humans have evaluated the fluency of our text to be I don't know four out of five uh and then another paper that says like three out of five like they use different humans different ways of like prom prompting the humans um so it's it's absolutely not comparable
okay so let's go back to some of the issues so as I said human judgments are regarded as the gold standard uh but definitely has issues uh first it's super slow um as you might expect humans are definitely not as fast as automatic uh metrics uh second at least in Academia it's it's still pretty expensive to do um because I mean when you pay well your workers um it's pretty expensive to do well uh human evaluation um another part is interannotator disagreement so if I take two random
people in this room and I ask them to evaluate the quality of a generated text I can assure you that you will really not agree uh so this is even if it especially if it's subjective it's really bad but even if you talk for like one hour before about uh like how you should be evaluating um uh Generations I can most likely guarantee you that you will you will still disagree on many of the evaluations and to give you an example uh when we were doing uh alpaca form last year which is uh something
where we basically had to take um some inputs and then take two models um think chat GPT alpaca and these type of models and you just uh have the two models predict an answer and then you ask the humans to say which answer they prefer this is a very simple task um and this is but I will talk about it later this is what like a lot of people basically use right now for evaluating um models like J GPT um so natural question is whether humans are good at doing that and what we saw is that so we were five
researchers doing that and the five of us we talked for like two or three hours we write wrote extremely detailed uh rubrics about how to do their evaluations and still we only agreed 67% of the time so 50% is like uh random uh and if we just label things independently we only uh agree 67% of the time and we really try to do our best like we were working on this thing so it's not as if we were trying to do it like quickly so really people disagree of course if you if you then allow like discussions between the
annotators then agreement actually improves uh but then it becomes even more like slower and more expensive intra annotator disagreement this is something that is extremely annoying which is that if I ask a human if I ask myself right now to evaluate something or like in three hours like after I have dinner or after I went to to run I will actually give different different annotations um yes to um you mean for validating yeah so this is a very good question honestly there's no good answer the usual way that people do it is that
you look at some statistical um like some stati iCal metrics basically where you're like okay I want to compare between these two models uh I'm going to look at I'm going to basically perform a t test and I'm I want to know that like my P value is less than a certain amount um what people usually do also when they have humans annotations um I unfortunately didn't put a slide on that but they have a metric for computing the intra annotator basically agreement and they try to achieve a certain intra
annotator agreement and if not they will essentially ask for more humans or for Rel labelings um yeah it's not reproducible and this is like partly because of the two things that we said before uh but also partly because um yeah I mean mostly because of the two things before so this is a an interesting paper um I think it's I I forgot which year I think it's from 2021 but I'm not sure uh where basically they say and I read from the abstract here just 5% of human evaluations are repeatable in the sense that there are
no prohibitive barriers to repetition and sufficient information about EXP experimental design uh is publicly available for rerunning them so this is a paper that analyzed I think 128 um different papers that were published across like five years I think between 2015 and 2020 um and they found that essentially only 5% of those papers were reproducible um uh so honestly working with humans is hard that's definitely something to remember uh another part is that humans only uh basically evaluate precision and
not recall so what I mean by that is that if I if I if you show me uh what the model generated I can only evaluate that generation I cannot gen evaluate all the other possible Generations I could have generated um because then you really have to sample a lot of things and that that will become way too slow and way too expensive and finally uh usually the incentives are not aligned so what you want is for the humans to basically do the best possible evaluations uh but what crowd workers usually want is basically to maximize
the the amount of money that they get paid uh per hour so to give you again a concrete example when we were doing alpaka Farm um I I think we were paying relatively well in the sense that we were paying a u 1.5 times the the minimum wage in California um and then we divided basically we we looked at how much time we would spend to do the thing like in the basically to evaluate a single example the best we could uh um and then we divided by that time to basically know how much how much we would pay for every example um and what
we realized is that they ended up being paid I think two or 2.5 times the minimum wage because they were just doing things like two three times faster than us uh and I don't I mean we could be slow but I think what was happening is that they were just trying to maximize the dollars that they were getting per hour and as a result they were uh finding like shortcuts for doing their evaluations um and this is something that you really see in the of papers uh for example in our case uh you saw that humans really preferred longer
answers and of course if you give me two uh two very long gener like two sorry generations and you ask me with minimal amount of work to say which one is better like if I see a longer one I'm like H probably there are more details proba it's better uh anyways it's not to say that everyone is like is like that but definitely it's it's the incentives are on line so you have to be careful of this uh other challenges uh first you have to decide how to descri the task uh you really have to give very detailed
rubrics for how the humans have to evaluate the task um then there's a question of how do you show the task to the humans uh for example the order in which you give examples actually really important uh the in our case because we had two examples side by side they're actually which one is on the left and which one is on the right is actually also very important so all these things really matter um of course you can randomize these things away but but it is like it adds challenges um what
metrics to use I mean this is not specific to humans uh selecting the annotators this is also very complicated uh you might think okay I have some money now I I can go on on Amazon M turkers and I can just ask them to uh evaluate uh or to do some annotations but in reality you want to have the good annotators so how it usually works in Amazon uh in in m is that basically you you uh say oh here's a task I want like 30 different people to do these annotations uh and then they start annotating and then you if they don't
achieve the level that you want you basically pay for what they they annotated until then and you you work with someone else afterwards uh so then there's a question of how do you decide whether they achieved the performance that you want uh so you probably have to do like some gold labeling before and then look at like some accuracies of how well and like some intra anator agreement with you and with like the other researchers on your team uh so it is very complicated and not only this you have
to monitor that over time um so there are many different ways you can monitor that over time looking again at the accuracy so maybe every let's say a typical thing is that every batch of example that you label you give a few you give a few examples that are actually uh ones that you already know what the Gold Label is and you see how well they're performing on that another way to look at is like the time that they take to annotate um yeah okay so that was about humans uh so human evaluation is hard but it is a
gold standard okay now let's talk about uh reference free evaluation and chat bots so so I already told you about uh about it before very briefly how do you evaluate something like chat GPT um this is extremely complicated because basically you could ask it any task you want um and it can answer text that is arbitrarily long and that just makes evaluation extremely hard um so as I suggested before the usual way that it's done is that you take two models you put them side by side you as the same
question and you just ask either some humans or some model as we will see afterwards uh which which one is better um so this is the most common Benchmark right now I would say for human evaluation it's called chatbot Arena uh where basically anyone can go online and just play with for free with some of like the best models out there and all they ask you is to say whether you prefer the one on the right or whether you prefer the one on the left essentially uh and then once they reach I think a crazy amount of data 200,000
human votes for example they basically add it to a leaderboard uh and the way they add it to leaderboard is that they um essenti I don't know if you know how chess works but they basically look at the ELO ratings um so it's they basically put everything as if it was a t tournament uh such that not every model has to uh play against every other model uh and then they get Elo Elo scores okay so what's missing with this side by side human evil as I said this is really the gold standard for
evaluation of CH chat LMS but there are still some challenges uh first like it's basically random people online uh that ask random questions and they provide like their preferences um so that might may not be representative although arguably when you have that many examples like it becomes actually pretty representative of what people would want Al um so it's probably better than whatever we have um but it is still not ideal and then really the big the big issue is cost uh this takes a huge Community
effort and a lot of people to work on that um also it takes a lot of time to get uh new models on The Benchmark and only the notable models so think like the openi models and the cloud and like the Google ones uh and the Facebook ones are going to be benchmarked uh you will never have for your random model 200,000 uh um people who are willing to annotate it for free um so this is an issue and again like as as we talked about in the first slide even for those big companies they can definitely not do that for like
development of their model uh this is something that comes at the end for maybe model selection okay so how do we make it faster um so one uh very natural uh solution is basically to ask uh a large language model to do the evaluation for you so imagine that I want to compare chat GPT with Moll I basically add G as GPT 4 to evaluate uh which one is better um this is surprisingly good and I will show you some results afterwards and some common versions are Paka eval and empty bench probably the two most common
ones um so when we started doing that that's a problem I told you about uh we started that around last year um and we found that using gp4 essentially for evaluation is at least if you look at the prices now would be 100 times faster and 100 times cheaper than if use human evaluations uh but and this is very surprising the agreement with humans actually higher than humans agree with themselves so what I mean by that is that if I ask so this is what we found if I ask four humans uh let's say I have
a pool of four humans and I take out one human and I look at the agreement between that that human preferences and the mode of the preferences of the three others and I I do that in a leave one out fashion and I look at this agreement uh this will be lower than if I ask um for the model to predict essentially the preference of the mode of the humans um so in some ways models are more highly correlated with humans than humans themselves which is very surprising and I will tell you about it in two seconds
a little bit more um when we did that we actually use that for uh collecting uh human preferences for rhf so that's what we call R AI as I think Arch told you about these things uh last week um so going back to this ISS or this like surprising result that actually models are more highly correlated with humans and humans themselves the reason why this is is because humans are actually uh have high inter annotate disagreement and have high variance essentially um models they will always be very consistent or maybe
not perfectly like there's still some some circity but essentially they will they will always predict the same uh label so they have very little variance so here what you see on this plot is on the Y sorry x-axis we estimated the the variance and you see that the human has a variance of like around 31 or 33 um well if you look at the red point this is basically if you just add gp4 to do evaluations so even though the bias is still pretty high um so bias by definition for humans is zero uh for
gbd4 it is like around 32% the viance is much lower um than than humans so this is why you can see that actually sometimes agreement is higher but that's really because there are there's no varant or very little Varan in uh in LMS um yeah does that make sense yeah lens is higher than a human sorry it means the internal cerence is higher than exactly so which which is actually a good sign because that means it's that's makes it much easier for for research the bad sign is that the bias
is still high yeah okay so things to be careful with when you work I mean this is both with humans and with uh llms uh there will be some spus correlations so we already talked about SP correlations but you will see a lot of those um one very common example is length so if you just as I told you before if you ask crowd workers which examples they prefer they are highly biased towards longer longer output so here the blue is humans it's around I think 70% preferences for longer outputs and and models are around
the same uh same bias um and another example is preference for lists so usually if you if you see lists in an output uh models prefer these these examples and models uh model and humans prefer these examples uh another another bias or SP correlation is a position I told you like how which one you put on the left which one do you put on the right when you compare to when you ask humans to to label there's the same thing with models but this is usually pretty easy to control for you just randomize both uh another issue is GPD
for Self Bias so very naturally you might like you might wonder if if I ask GPD for to to evaluate itself like it will probably bias it will prefer itself than other models uh and this is true but less than what you might think I will tell you about later okay so Al EV TR wait until what time do I have you have 30 minutes oh thanks great um okay alpaka eval so alpaka eval is The Benchmark that we developed when when we were working on alpaca um so as I told you before we need um one thing which is very important is what you use
for development um so basically for high propri tuning so what what we did is that we basically did not trust many of the benchmarks out there at this point uh for instruction following so we just developed a very small Benchmark for ourselves and this is what we were doing for I tuning uh and then it kind of became its own thing um so alpaka eval in a few numbers it has very high correlation with chatboard Arena so the ranking if you look at the the correlation between the ranking in chadbad Arena and and in alpaka eval
it's 98% so very high and it takes around 3 minutes and $10 to to evaluate um and the way it works I think I already mentioned it but basically you take an instruction you generate an output from one one model and then from another model that you're you're comparing it to um and you as gp4 to basically give the probability that it prefers uh the model that you're evaluating versus the Baseline that you're comparing to um and then you do some reweighting and the reason why you
do some reweighting is because uh these models as I said are very uh biased towards longer outputs so you want to rewe such that uh if it's a longer output you give it a slightly less High preferences uh High preference and then you average across your entire data set and you get a red rate um so that's how it works any questions cool um so system level correlation so here what you see on the x-axis is basically alaka I mean a slight transform of it but essentially a back a EV valid scores and on the y-axis
is this chatbot Arena which is the gold standard and you see that things are relatively highly correlated and on the on the lower plot you see basically the correlation between different Benchmark and chatbot Arena and you see like mty bench and alpaka Eva which are the two ones that use llms for evaluations are relatively highly correlated with chadbad Arena and mlu which is the automated one that doesn't use anlm is also very highly correlated um so I told you very briefly about the fact that we had to do some reweighting
um so I'm not going to tell you how we do it but I want to tell you why we do it um one of the issues that we realized uh a little bit too late is that if if you take something like GPT 4 um and you just ask it you prompt it to be much more detailed to basically provide much more detailed answers uh its win rate so its performance on your on your benchmark goes from 50% to 64.3 uh so that's this one 64.3 uh if you're ask it to be more concise like it decreases to 22.9 and it really doesn't fit like our mental model
of what benchmarks should be doing um if I just change tweak a little bit The Prompt I don't want my model to change completely its ranking um so that's why we have to do some reting and you see that after the reting uh you basically have that the uh uh performance after you as the model to be more of a boss is is very close to the performance uh without any any prompt uh tuning cool so I told you slight or very briefly before about self bias I do want to say that I'm pretty surprised about
this result but actually Self Bias exists but is not as high as you might uh think so here you see on the xaxis the ranking um or like the the different models that you're evaluating and on the sorry that's on the rows and on the columns you see who is evaluating which model are you using for evaluation and you actually see that regardless of the model that you that you evaluate with uh the ranking will be the same so even though it's true that um if I look at um mol uh evaluated by mol it gives itself
a much higher accuracy uh it is it still prefers Claud and gp4 uh so it's not as bad as what you may think it's still bad though cool okay so that leads me to talking about current evaluation of llms so i' would say there are three main ways that people currently evaluate llms um the first one is perplexity um which is essentially just looking at training losses or validation losses um the second one is basically averaging everything uh which is actually surprisingly more common than what you
may think and the third one is uh is this Arena like or where you basically have comparisons between models and either use humans or use uh um models to do the evaluation and usually how it works is that pre-trained model let's say the new like when L 4 comes out or like when GPT 5 comes out they B basically mostly show perplexity and like average over everything and the fine-tune models they usually tend to show average over everything and um uh Arena like performance under Arena like models uh and the reason why is because
uh models that are pre that are fine-tuned usually the the log likelihood that they predict is is not um yeah it's not calibrated for your for your data set so what do I mean by everything um I would say the two most common uh benchmarks that basically look at everything are Helm and hugging face openm uh leaderboard it's really just a collection of a lot of different autom automatically evaluated benchmarks um and you evaluate across all of them um so what are some of the common Benchmark
that we use uh one is um yeah measuring like math performance so GSM 8K that's a pretty common one that's basically grade school math mlu uh is multiple choice question answering on like Math Science History uh legal bench is is uh is on the legal aspect then you have Med QA so this I I believe this is for Helm Med QA is uh um yeah medical licensing exams so you basically ask many many different questions that you can uh automatically evaluate um and you hope that by taking averages um it will say like how well
your model performs so that's kind of like the newer version of super glue I would say um one data set that I want to highlight which is probably or one Benchmark which is probably the most widely used and the one that people believe the most is mlu so massively multitask language understanding um so this is I I think maybe Archard mentioned it last week but this is basically um uh multiple choice uh questions on 57 different tasks you so you have tasks like formal logic conceptual physics econometrics and and
uh these type of tasks so here's an example um what is true for type 1 a supernova uh this type occurs in binary system this type occurs in young galaxies and you basically have to say which answer so that seems very simp I mean the task is not simple but the way you evaluate seems simple uh and then like high school biology in a population of Gira an environmental and then you this is an example of directional selection um so that seems simple but actually it's it's also more complicated
than what you might think um and I think I will tell you okay I will tell you about it later um but that's that's mo one of the most common probably the most common Benchmark and what people actually look at uh for example when Mark Zuckerberg like said that LMA 3 was out uh he yeah he talked about MML U scores which I I find kind of crazy but yeah um other capabilities that people look at coding uh coding is a very common one that people evaluate on um for two different reasons one because coding uh is usually
if you perform well on code you usually actually these models perform well on reasoning um which is actually pretty cool um so that's like highly correlated with things that people care about uh two I mean a lot of us are Cod is so uh we like to have uh uh better models for helping us coding and three the other point is that it's actually pretty easy to evaluate uh because you can write test cases so you basically as the model to generate very long uh uh code or like functions to to to do something and then
you just run the test and you see whether it it succeeds or not yes sorry going back to the prev evaluations some of them was short answ currently um how would you validate like short QA type of thing where it's like multiple choice makes sense but if it's like short answer QA how would you say something is correct as an automatic met uh think specifically to the top yeah I actually don't know huh I actually don't know yeah I should check sorry um so I don't know specifically for this one but Hot Pot QA
and beer QA are other QA uh data sets and then they look at F1 for the true and false and then they also have an exact match which is pretty punitive because like if you say President Reagan and the answer is like President Ronald Reagan like will de you but anyway so they use like an exact M on that yeah um cool thanks okay Sam you coding another one that people start looking at are agents I think shakar is going to give election on it uh so I'm not going to talk too much about it but like one cool thing that LMS can do
right now is basically call apis uh and then take actions in the real world essentially or like take control of your computer um you should not give it control to your computer uh so a natural question is like how do you evaluate these type of things this is a real challenge um because I mean the biggest challenge is that if you for example if I really wanted to to evaluate like how good it is at coding or like how good it is at doing things in my terminal I need to give it access to my terminal and I
really don't want to give my LM access my terminal um so you really need to sandbox environments for the specific cases of terminal I mean it's pretty easy to sandbox but once you want to do evaluation of like a model that that I don't know P people on slack or like writes things in your emails then you have to write an entire uh uh sandbox environment for all the applications that you want your llms to have access to uh so this is actually really complicated and something that people
really have to deal with in in kind of the real world uh at least we have to because right now it's still not in production okay the last part is uh or the penultimate one perplexities uh so one thing which is very uh surprising um at least the first time you see it is that really the performance that you have on um pre-training is extremely highly correlated uh with basically performance on any Downstream task um at least for the current types of LMS so what I mean by this is that if you just
look at your training performance uh just predicting the next word it's extremely highly correlated so this is the x- axxis which is essentially perplexities um and the y- AIS which is just the average over like many different tasks what you will see is that tasks that perform well on your uh on perplexities will actually have high uh High average scores um and as a result a lot of people actually end up when they develop just looking at perplexities and they just trust it enough that they don't need to uh do the
downstream evaluations I would not recommend doing it but if you have to have something like quick and dirty it usually works pretty well um one thing to be careful with though is that the perplexities are not going to be comparable across different data sets um so you really have to be careful with like what perplexities you're looking at and two it will depend on the tokenizer um so if you have like Lama 3 or and and you compare it to Gemini even um uh yeah even on the same data set it's going to
give different different scores and it's not comparable uh yes uh the the easy answer I mean it's not the only answer but the easy answer is that if the vocabulary changes the the size of the vocabulary changes uh then clearly the type of um I mean everything is not on the like the upper bound is different sequence uh a sequence like normal yeah but I'm talking but I'm not talking about that I'm talking about the fact that I mean just think about it if you have a vocabulary size of one oh then I
have to always predict the same thing so like you you're like the basically your entropy depends your entropy is uper bounded by log of like the cardinality of your vocabulary size so you're going to depend on that cool and the last one is Arena like as I already told you basically you compare different models uh you make them fight essentially against each other and you have U um ELO ratings at the end so that's really a more General way of saying it is I really just let the users decide uh and that works also pretty
well okay issues and challenging with issues and challenges with current evaluations uh first consistency issues uh if you look at question answering uh sorry um multiple choice questions um if you just change so you see on the top left and top right if you just change ABCD to like random symbols uh the the generations that you will give are actually going to be different and then the rankings between different models will be different um so even things that are very simple like multiple choice
like like selecting out of four choices uh will be very dependent on exactly like how you format uh these choices uh and one real example that's that's what I was alluding to before is mlu so mlu seems really simple to evaluate you just ask it to say like what which one of the four uh the model prefers um but actually for a very long time I think for nearly one year uh there were three main implementation of mlu and people were comparing between those three having no idea that like those three
gave like different scores um and the reason like the two main differences were one people use different prompts so that clearly will give different answers but two they were using different ways of sampling to get the the actual to get the actual like most likely prediction so one of them for example was saying um I have the four choices now to get my most likely uh let's say that the correct answer is D um I will just look look at the most likely answers out of ABCD even though like Z zigot was
another answer that has a higher likelihood uh I will not look at it because I will I will basically do constraint decoding um and if I do constraint decoding here I will say that the correct answer is d uh but if I actually just look at the most likely token I will not get the correct answer so like those were two different implementation and a third different implementation which uh seems really different is that instead of generating the correct uh token which is basically the letter ABCD you can look
at after this question what is the likelihood that the answer sorry that the model would generate this so you would look at the log likelihood um or like the perplexity essentially of predicting this thing log likelihood of predicting that and that gives very different answers uh so if you look at the top right uh you see that Lama 65b MML on Helm was 63 3.7 and the original mmu 63.6 but on harness uh which is the thing that actually hugging face uses is 48.8 so that's like a huge difference
yeah what is Helm harness and original it matches to these three things there uh yeah one I can't remember which one does what but each of them does something different actually now it's not true anymore so the middle column change what they're doing so they start matching the other two ones uh but at that time they weren't uh I'm not sure which one my guess was would be that they did the the last one uh but I'm not in show okay questions cool another issue contamination um so here you have harass
he if you don't follow him on Twitter you should um I and he basically said that he was looking at um like code benchmarks and he was saying that pre pre 2021 uh I can't remember which Mar or gbt 4 was getting 10 out of 10 on questions on code Force but after 2021 or like more recent problems it was getting zero out of 10 which seems very very uh strange uh so that really strongly points to the fact that it was contaminated and was probably the model was probably pre-trained or like that
data set or the code Force data set was probably in the pre-training data set and of course if you I mean essentially you do you do training on your test set then you're going to perform really well um and Suzanne said also to follow also said something similar for uh F 1.5 um which is a model from Microsoft so what is challenging here is that with' closed models um I mean there are two things actually that are challenging one is that those are pre-trained on so much data that even if we had access to the data it would be
hard to actually know what they like if they were pre-trained on your test set but two those are all close Source models so you really don't even have access to a data set so you have no idea if they were pre-train on that data um overfitting issues that's also relatively related uh but could be slightly different uh so here you see how much time it took for standard data sets to achieve uh quot like squary quotes uh human level performance um and what you see is that on the recent ones
where you really have this pre-training in less than like six months uh you perform at human level performance um we don't really know if it's because of the contamination or if it's simply that like a lot of people are basically developing and trying to do Hy prar tuning on these test sets uh we don't know why but it's clearly an issue with over overfitting um so how do you alleviate that one you can have private test sets uh so there's a paper from I think two weeks ago uh that presented GSM 1K which
is the same thing as the GSM 8K that we saw before which is the the math uh data set but um tries to reamp basically regenerate or resample this data set uh or recollect this data set and then they look at how well different models um perform on both the GSM 1K and the GSM 8K and what you see is that at least the open source models they they perform much worse on the on a new data set than on the one that people are able to tune on um this is not true though for like cloud and gp4 another one is Dynam Ben or just
Dynamic test sets uh so ideally every X number of days you would basically have new instructions or new inputs to the models and and your data set would basically be dynamic that's essentially also what chatbot Arena does so uh that definitely helps um another way of alleviating contaminators is that you may try to estimate or like to look at whether the the models were actually trained on your on your test set so one very simple way of doing it which actually works I think relatively well um is just looking at
the probability of different answers and you will see that if uh your model is really sure about a certain answer then probably was strein on that answer um another one which which is also really cool is um looking at the order of your test set so if your model was uh if a model was trained or pre-trained on the test set then most likely it thinks that example two comes after example one so if you switch example one and example two and you see drops in log likelihoods then most likely the model was actually
pre-trained on that data set um cool any questions here okay so another issue is that I mean really there's a monoculture of NLP Benchmark benchmarking what I mean by this is mostly the fact that we all just look at English um and this is a paper from 2021 2022 I think but they look at ACL 2021 which is the probably the the most common uh um conference in or like yeah conference in in in NLP and they look at the best papers so the oral papers and they saw that out of the 461 papers uh 70% of them only look at English and 40%
of them only look at accuracy so essentially just performance um so there are very few papers that look at multilinguality and like uh even like efficiency and interpretability or fairness um and there's a similar paper from that analyzes another conference in 2008 and it was essentially the same finding so unfortunately it doesn't seem to improve over time um the thing is there are actually a lot of benchmarks for multilinguality uh I just highlight a few here uh Mega Global bench extreme uh those have at
least uh 30 40 languages and many many different tasks um so it's not that we don't have the benchmarks is that there's no incentives um unfortunately in Academia to actually train or like sorry to um to evaluate on those benchmarks um so if you have the chance use those benchmarks um another issue is that really we reduce everything to a single metric so I already told you before the way we aggregate metrics this is usually kind of broken in in some of these super benchmarks but also we only look at
performance and in in in the real world like we really care about computational efficiency too we also care about biases and we care about many other aspects and like most of these benchmarks don't consider those um another part is that we usually average across every example uh we just say that every example has the same value essentially the same weight um so this is definitely unfair for like minoritized groups but more than this I think if for example if you think about like um agents where maybe
one example will be like how well it performs on um I don't know writing codee that will actually be put in production versus just like uh like answering your daily question about like where I don't know where to buy the best burger um like the value that you will get out of these examples are very different and we right now when we evaluate stuff we don't actually consider that so that's I think a real a real issue um and also we basically we don't take into account that different
people have different preferences um so a few outs one considering computational efficiency so ml puff has a great Benchmark uh where basically instead of trying to maximize the performance on a certain Benchmark they say I want to achieve that performance in the least amount of time um so now you basically consider both like accuracies and like speed either for training or for for inference uh for biases uh dis remal is a good data set from um uh entropic where basically they they have some templates um and they so
they try to ask questions like uh uh knowing whether someone should should keep their insurance or not and they have templates where they change um like the race or like the gender of of the in the template of the person and they see how the decisions made by the model would change um and I mean unfortunately but unsurprisingly uh you will see that some groups are much more discriminated than others uh other biases in our evaluation so I already told you slightly about the multilingual issues but honestly this
this issue about English is like much more prevalent than you would think for example blur and RK they really assume that you basically have access to words like you know how to tokenize and how to get words so I used to work with uh Tai and Vietnamese with Vietnamese you have spaces in between words and T you have no spaces between words like you have no idea how to run like blue Rouge like really these it's much more than just the data like all all our algorithms are are really like focused on English or at
least Western languages uh bias uh biased llm uh based evaluations so one thing is that I told you about is that it's really cool because now you can use essentially gp4 for doing uh uh uh labeling um but that also means that given that gp4 is very consistent if it has some biases then most of essentially the NLP community will have these um biases scaled up essentially um so one Benchmark which tries to look at uh whose opinions llms reflect uh by default uh this is actually pretty cool work that looks at
the uh output distribution of llms on public opinion surveys so just trying to understand um whether llms um uh reflect opinions from from which groups and they find that at least after when you only do pre-training uh the models actually relatively well uh they are not too optimized to a single group uh but after so this is in red but after fine-tuning uh you basically see that the models really start being optimized for certain preferences uh which is unsurprising because that's how we actually train the
model um and typically these models are actually uh um mostly show uh uh ref es from um actually the answer as if they were from uh I mean white and uh Southeast Asian so I think the selfie station is actually pretty interesting I think it's probably because a lot of these models were uh the human data that was used for supervised fine tuning and for HF was actually labeled by people in Southeast Asia uh which would explain why these models have um these type of views and usually also highly educated
okay so this is the main challenge uh the challenges of all challenges uh we saw that there are many challenges in evaluation in in at least in academic benchmarking but the biggest one is that really there's no incentives for us to move to anything else um and this is uh actually pretty interesting paper that looks at uh machine translation between all the papers of or many papers um from 2019 to 2020 in machine translation and they found that 82% of papers they only evaluated blue scores and as we said
like blue scores have many many issues and if you see like we know that there are many better uh metrics um but still people are not incentivized to look at anything else and actually reviewers will usually ask you to show uh performance on Blue scores so it's not even that your incentivized not to look at something else or also incentivized to continue and it kind of makes sense because you want to be able to compare to methods from two three years ago go but it also means that we we it's it's
hard for the academic field um to change to other benchmarks um but this is really specific to Academia like in reality if you know that your metric is bad just switch um okay evaluation takeaways uh so first we I I mentioned that there were different uh types of evaluation and different uh desired properties for different types of evaluation uh then I talked about close ended tasks um and how you evaluate those the fact that it's basically standard machine learning um but that you have to think carefully
even though it's standard machine learning of how you evaluate them uh then there are open-ended tasks uh where you look at content overlap metrics typically uh so things like blue uh uh and Rouge um and Bird score and then you have chatbot evaluations uh which is extremely difficult um but uh people have start has have started doing with uh using essentially LM based evaluations um and then we talked about challenges one of them being consistency the other one contamination uh and the third one biases um in reality honestly
the best evaluation is just check your outputs um so I think too many people they just believe numbers in reality like never just believe numbers like I I remember when we did initially alpaca like we we kind of believed our alpaka eval but uh but once we saw playing with it that's when we were like okay this thing is actually I mean at that time good now it's it would be a pretty bad model but at that time we're like okay this thing is actually pretty good um we should do something about it even though
on maybe standard academic benchmarks it was pretty bad um so yeah don't rely on numbers and I'm happy to what time is it to take any other questions uh that you may have yes question about so there's this whole issue of bias which we're trying which we really trying to deal with but we're sweeping under the rug here so if we have a problem in which we're dealing with a very specialized domain and yes we try and go and run and run um reference re vales using like let's say gbg4 yeah uh sh like is it
considered bad practice to be checking a subset of these gp4 evals ranking them as ourselves and then like and then using and then using ourself uh like inserting ourself and and our bias into this process by actually looking at many many many data points uh so just to make sure I understand your question you're saying that if we try to look ourselves at the answers we might be incorporating some biases there yes but we should look at the answers to make sure that gp4 isn't being biased when it looks at the
answers there's this tension here and I don't know what the cuz in a in a controlled scientific experiment you would blind yourself to looking at these answers how do you deal with this yeah that's a good question I actually don't quite know but one thing um I actually feel less concerned about biases of a single person uh my issue with the gp4 biases is that it's the same across every model so things really scale up and kind of uh um it's really it becomes a monoculture and I think that that I
think that's less that's much worse than if everyone incorporates a little bit of the biases that they have in their Direction I'm not saying that that's the the best answer but I think it's slightly better than than just going with whatever they have yeah how does one following up on that how does avoid a situation if we're like one is trying to solve a problem with a model yeah uh and uh one evaluates it with GPT chat gp4 yeah uh and then one starts to to like look at it and say okay is this is
this good and stuff and then one goes okay this is great and everyone else in the world and GT4 thinks it's a terrible terrible model and it's just someone being and it's just some academic being like uh like pressuring themsel into publishing something that doesn't actually work how do you how does the field structurally avoid situations like that um well I I think that's one reason why they want standardized benchmarks and why all every reviewer actually wants standardized benchmarks because
because at least even though everyone knows that they're wrong they understand how they are wrong um so I think that's like one perspective another thing which is not doesn't completely answer your question but but um I think could be a potential solution um is that how I view gp4 is just something that is really good at performing what I want it to perform uh right now the thing is I I not very specific about what I wanted to perform um and as a result it will it will basically come in with its own biy
that that come from its pre-training data or or fine tring data um a potentially better way of doing it is that I could write exactly what I want so right now when we say when we do the the prompting to gp4 I basically ask a question simple question like how good is the summary uh out of five uh but a much better way would probably be writing a very detailed rubric of everything that has to be uh in this answer for it to be a good answer and if you think about it this is exactly what like professors do uh when they evaluate
for class like they basically say Okay Yan is a TA but I cannot trust him per like blindly so what I will do is that I will write a very detailed rubric and I trust that he can apply that rubric and I think that's also how we should be thinking about gp4 and this is not how we currently do it any other questions